lundi au saut de zoo de san antonio vous
avez la possibilité pour 5 $ de baptiser
un cafard avec le prénom de votre ex à
séoul non mais c'est une info voilà où
baptisé un cabas et où il va ce cafard
voilà par exemple pour benaïssa il
s'appelle richard k way voilà vous est
forte car issa non non mais on doit vous
sortez machinerie sefrou ça franchement
à quoi vous quel est l'animal qui
correspond le mieux à votre ex
et pourquoi tu as tout nouveau site y
soit à ckoi la tenue du liban
[Rires]
c'est une espèce les gras dur
aujourd'hui
l'animal une espèce d'accord m ben je
vois pas qui est invité tous ses propos
version ne concerne que lui mais c'est
un ami voilà oui vous ou une souris une
souris pourquoi sur une bibliothèque à
l'elysée tout le temps non ah ouais bah
vous vous étiez avec une meuf alizés
tout en prêtant témoin aussi c'est vrai
mais ces champs mais alors ne parlez
jamais vous étiez comme ça dans l'eee en
train de dire des trucs à quoi nous
assistons dans le lit alors ont misé
ensemble voilà chacun son livre non mais
sérieux quoi partout partout partout
partout tu es plus minus que vous avez
déjà fait l'amour en lisant en disant
oui et bien sûr non soir je recommence
mais bon les ans kelly oui la tob magic
blessure c'est possible de faire les
deux en même temps c'est vrai mais oui
je pars avec un peu d'imagination on
voit bien ouais c'est au sein dirais moi
j'ai alors moi je moi j'ai fait une fois
enlisé sur qui faisant série alors oui
il vaut mieux comment un char pourquoi
indépendant intelligent ouais bon ex
ils sont donnés ils permettent avaient
tous les deux moustache jean-michel les
mots moitié tapir et non moi toi quoi
moitié de tapir moitié puis c'est à dire
voler oui on a déjà volé et puis
d'accord tout cas vous faites pas votre
meilleure émission pas commencé
justement c'est bien ce à quoi il sert l
escargot
pourquoi il m'avait des bourgognes et
bavay il était lent pour ça que c'est
terminé c'est quoi une lionne non
indomptables sauvage elle me fait
pendant les trains soient way ah oui
maladie est à griffes un peu le cerveau
on va faire un scanner quand même nom
mais sans à wemmel plantait c'est que
j'avais mais à lyon la mare chocolatées
ou l'animal mais aussi des enfants ou
alors quoi un tir excellent non moi tout
comme kelly mais non non moi une limace
parce qu'il m'avait sont tout le monde
mais comment on était chez tout le monde
il n'avait pas de maison dans tout aucun
risque les séquences ce texte parce que
c'est quand j'étais ado quand il ya ce
sera jean michel d'ailleurs l'aspect
jean-michel ouais bah oui comme quoi
tous les jean michel est une malédiction
oui oui moi et ne viennent une ouïe and
away parce que quand on est blessé le
goût des bords au la lune on sent qu'il
a fait et fait encore plus encore fanny
moi c'était un kangoo accord voiture
c'est une voiture
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cet adn
parce qu'il souhaitait tout ce qui bouge
non pas que tout ça là non c'était un
autre temps un autre hôtel ce qui tout
ce qui bougeait pas écouté plus personne
ne bouge autour de lui il faut faire des
1 2 3 soleil
et ouais et castaldi arrête de draguer
tout le monde subit l'ipad la drague est
pressé il fait ses yeux comme ça
[Rires]
total
mais ferme sa gueule tu fais packaging
m'a dit je crois qu'elle va sortir avec
toi allez on y va
[Rires]